but first up he is the host of MSNBC's
the last word with lawrence O'Donnell
his book deadly force a police shooting
and my family's search for the truth is
now reissued all right so Donald did you
did you get the note from Giuliani about
the questions I want who's gonna be
shorter than you Val you know
conservatives do watch this show and
they're gonna see us talk about Trump
mhm and then we know what they're gonna
say Trump derangement syndrome this is
what they this is the thing with them
you if you watch Fox News I have to a
little bit you have to see what they're
saying this is what they say they think
we're deranged and I wanted to ask you
what what do you do about that because
you can't say to people we have the
truth because then you sound like the
guy it and Jesus can't how you ignore it
because it's it's just a device they
have nothing good to say they have
nothing worthy to say in defense of the
President or in defense of what you were
just saying about Wilbur Ross right they
have there no one's gonna from that side
is gonna come back with any facts for
you about that hundred and twenty
million dollars at Wilbur Ross who is
accused of playing around with so
they're gonna say that you are just
arranged and you're saying this because
he's associated with Trump that's you
just don't fall for that you just keep
going and detail what that 120 million
dollars is about that's what that's what
we're doing you know in my hour of TV
and and Rachel Maddow does the most
masterful job of that every night
she never gets distracted by any of that
or write any of the accusations any of
the adjectives she is just on the the
fact case of this and she's a model for
all of us so all right so if we can't
convince them how about convincing our
side you can't convince them by the way
case so you're trying to get you know
roughly 51% if you can get that that's
supposed to work in a democracy you know
and anything you get more than that is
great but you know a big run away the
biggest landslide presidential elections
of my lifetime were you know the high
50s sixty percent was the highest
anybody ever got while I've been alive
so they say you know that can they say
now that the Democrats actually have to
win by twelve just to win because of
gerrymandering and and voter suppression
and felons can vote oh they have so many
ways of cheating and there's so much
better at playing the game sometimes
they just better outplay us I mean
Hillary didn't go to Wisconsin that
wasn't a good thing but they also know
how to cheat better and are much more
open to doing cheating and we have an
incredibly cheetah bull system right
thanks to the enduring electoral college
yeah which is those guys made some
mistakes you know slaves of them right
but they also did some things that made
perfect sense at the time
you know when Rhode Island was this big
and New York was this big right they had
no idea there was gonna be a thing
called California that was gonna be this
big right and then they were gonna have
these little Dakotas Rio that had a lot
of land and very few people they didn't
know that that was gonna be the mix of
the electoral college so that a majority
of voters could be denied their choice
of who the president should be well
there shouldn't be two Dakotas there's
that one is ridiculous that but high are
we
I always say we need that's where we
need to start we need to start with the
Ducati
but also I must say if Republic if the
situation in Puerto Ricans and people in
Washington DC voted Republican
Republicans would have found a way to
make them States by now but Democrats
don't play that game well but here's how
they would have found a way to do it
because Democrats would have done the
honorable thing and said to Puerto Rico
what we've said to them from the start
which is you are not a colony you have
your own ability to make a choice about
your relationship to this country you
can choose Commonwealth status which is
what they choose
you could choose independence and have
nothing to do with us if you want to or
you can choose statehood we've always
said it's up to them to vote on it and
so if if were tako voted for statehood
now Republicans would say absolutely not
we're not giving it to you
Democrats would have done the honorable
thing all the way through because they
actually take principles like that to be
to be real things and to be serious this
is a new level of political corruption
because it's a corruption of ideas we
all we've always had ways of trying to
get at the money corruption and we pay a
lot of attention to it but what happens
when the ideas of a party or a group of
political actors are completely
corrupted and that's what we're seeing
you saw it with Merrick garland you saw
it with you don't get a vote on a
Supreme Court justice and now you're
seeing it with they're gonna rush one
and violate their own principles of not
obtaining all the kind of documents that
they used to obtain on Supreme Court
nominees Chuck Grassley chairing the
committee just said oh oh we can't get
them in time never mind we'll just we'll
just have the hearing right after Labor
Day anyway so I could go on and on yeah
so the election is in 90 days or
something like that how do you think the
Democrats are gonna blow it
that they're so good at it and there's
this blue wave predicted and you know I
think you and I are very close on policy
we're not always close on prediction
what do you think is gonna happen I do
think the we will the Democrats will
well you know this Wow
I'll predict something but I've never
predicted congressional elections
because I worked in the Congress I
worked in the Senate I know how complex
that is and so I'd never made an attempt
to try to figure out what are all those
districts gonna do and who's gonna flip
and all that and there are experts who
do it and like Charlie cook and I just
kind of listened to them and I and I
really have never had an original
thought about this thing about who's
gonna win in a house race coming up and
so and you've got a congressman coming
on is going to answer that for you so I
all the indicators all the political
arithmetic everything we see that
Hillary was gonna be President no but
this is well no it didn't no it didn't
because the the Hillary was always
partying polling within the margin of
error against Donald Trump
she was always polling within that
margin she never cleared a lead over him
that was outside of the margin of error
so the polls are never telling you a
specific number they're telling you a
band of possibility right you know it's
not like when we take your temperature
that's 98.6 it's as if we took your
temperature and we said it's anywhere
between 92 and 98 right and that's what
polling is and and for the sake of so
public consumption they specify a number
but it never then they ask you to
predict it how will the how will the
Trump era end or will it well you know I
gave up predicting when I remember
sitting on Morning Joe when Donald Trump
in the primaries went from 6% to 12% in
the polls and I said with all the
authority I could muster you don't think
it's gonna get any higher than that do
you and and I think Joe did and others
did and I didn't so I gave up predicting
shortly after that when he was at 24 and
and
if but if I have to I would say the most
likely ending of it is when Elizabeth
Warren or whoever the Democratic nominee
is beats him in the next
election you think he'll leave you to go
so we are getting into predictions yeah
now you think if he loses the election
he will just greet her at the door on
January 20 it's yeah it's not up to him
has nothing to do with him oh it has
nothing to do
ryoga's yeah because what else she
becomes president because of the time
today not because the night thing he
does what when it's not if he well the
the the Chief Justice of Rights a
Supreme Court will administer the oath
to her no matter where it is and he
doesn't have to show up he never has to
concede doesn't have to do a thing the
second she takes that oath she's the
president he isn't any longer Secret
Service will physically remove him from
the building
did you ever have to remove a tick from
your dog I just want you have a secret
service is good at that okay your book
very important book we're gonna talk
about issues like that on the panel but
it was the first one 25 years ago they
really talked about police brutality and
in the black community
yeah you've reissued it yeah III wrote
this book over 30 years ago deadly
forced the first book out there about
the problems involved with police use of
deadly force the first thing I ever
wrote was an op-ed piece for the New
York Times in 1979 it was about police
use of deadly force was the first time
that the New York Times in print
acknowledged that there was a problem
and so I've been on it for a long time
and four years ago this week was when
Michael Brown was killed in Ferguson
that changed everything and it changed
everything because of the community's
reaction to it we hadn't seen a reaction
to a police shooting like that since the
invention of cable news we had seen them
before we had giant community reaction
around the country but it was localized
for Arthur McDuffie in Miami in 1980 and
and other others around the country this
was the first time all of the apparatus
of modern media social media was there
and and on the street covering every
minute of it and so finally America woke
up only four years ago and by America of
course I mean white America because
black America always knew there was this
problem they always knew that police
officers in their community were much
more inclined to serve and protect
themselves than the people they were
assigned to
I'm Gladys Rock and drink and glad
you're on the air Lawrence Oh God
[Music]